hi
hello everybody can you hear me okay is
it okay um
my name is mike butcher uh during the
day
my day job is i'm editor at large for
tech crunch a little blog you may have
heard of
and at night i fight brexit yes
oh i might possibly might have some
fellow fighters with me
in the room we were a little bit
frustrated
that the technology industry was not
quite
getting involved in the whole issue and
um
all the stats basically prior to the
referendum showed that
the vast majority of technology
companies uh were pro
for remaining in the eu and so and
we there was a couple of other industry
bodies like one called
tech uk who were sort of towing the
government line and we thought
you know what we're going to do
something about that so we got together
and we credited this thing called tech
for uk
um and we got a bunch of ceos to sign up
there's actually
150 end in the end to just say
publicly declare that they said
basically
we should give the people of britain a
final say
on the whole brexit issue we know
we know what we're dealing with now
we've been through a two-year process of
of extremely polite debate
um and uh and stuff like that
so you know let's give the public
another chance and that was our idea
and we got a bunch of ceos to sign up to
that and we thought okay what else can
we do well let's do some
hacking let's develop some products so
we got some people together
um and we started to do some hackathons
um
the some of the ideas really one of the
issues as you probably realize is that
um a lot of these campaigns that happen
online are sort of you know somebody
tweeting or somebody putting up a
facebook page or whatever
we wanted to do scalable technology
products which would have an inherent
virality
and actually serve the community serve
the serve the the
british people as it were to give them
information to help them make decisions
and to and to allow people to be more
informed
so the idea is to develop these scalable
products um
and also obviously everyone wants to
know what mps are thinking because mps
are very crucial to all of this
so we want to uh work out what they're
thinking um
and we we've done that because we were
partnering with a fantastic organization
called best for britain.org which is i'm
just going to check if i'm
over on it um which is a non-partisan
non-aligned organization so you all
heard of the big
people's vote campaign which is uh
awesome and fantastic but it
largely is how involves lots of
politicians and is quite
a bit a little bit of heavily
politicized whereas best of britain is
just
we want to stop brexit we want to have a
final vote that's all we want to do and
if we do that we'll disband
so that's what why we look like working
for them we work very closely with them
and we got a bunch of other people
involved et cetera so but we want more
um so sorry that's best for britain um
now i'll do a quick advert for them
because
we're doing some adverts but we we are
looking for data scientists
to come and join us but just here's a
couple of examples of the kind of things
we've done
now i'm working with two fantastic
people over here stand up guys
and andreas and kiana kiana
in the green obviously and um andreas
is working on um some projects with us
and kiana is specifically working on
my eu now can you believe ladies and
gentlemen
that nobody had ever plotted on a map
what the eu had done for us and so
incredibly enough we actually managed to
i don't know how you guys did it but um
i'm not the data scientist as you can
probably tell but it was it was actually
really really hard to get this
information out of the eu because
they're not actually brilliant
sort of you know they don't really do
things they just hear oh yeah here's
look at
all these pdfs i'm like okay so
anyway we managed to do it and if you go
to my eu dot uk works really well on
mobile as well it
you will be able to find that uh the
local school that got eu funding
and they've also now plotted um
how many eu staff there on are in every
hospital in the united kingdom
so you can go to the uh hospital which
where theresa may recently launched the
uh nhs
long-term plan and find out that it had
about 50 million pounds worth of eu
funding
and has about 200 200 uh eu
staff uh on my eu so that's pretty cool
um
it got uh tweeted by turned out by jk
rowling and hugh grant
and we are doing many more products um
we've also done final say dot
app final say dot app um you go to your
uh
it's a mobile web app you go there you
type in your post code you get your mp
you record them a message it gets sent
to them privately for a private inbox
if you want to send them a private
message or it can be public
and that is going viral at the moment
and uh and you
we publish the public the publicly
public public
messages are published on soundcloud and
you can listen to them they're quite
visceral
actually to listen to people why they
would like a final say on the whole
issue um and uh
so we yeah so as i said that's how we
did my uk we've had incredible number of
users
and it's still ticking over at the
moment we've got some launch
products and we've now got some some
under development
and one of the big pro issues that we've
realized is we want to put everything in
one place and we want to develop a
platform
so that people can go and find their
local mp not necessarily by postpo
code but by where they live we want them
to
uh be able to find out what their mp
thinks about brexit
we want to think we want to make it
easier for people to write to them
things like that
um and we've got tad more for instance
we've got a shopping bus we've got a
data science
project where we want to find out how
much it cost to do your weekly shop
and then what's it going to be like now
and what's going to be like after brexit
visions of the road and things like that
but we'll see
how it goes um so the next phase is we
want to scale up we've got our own slack
group we've got about 133 members
it's various people it's data people
it's uh
it's ui ux it's developers engineers you
name it
uh front end back end the whole works um
two minutes yup so we want developers to
work data scientists social media gurus
you name it and we want backers for our
products we want you to take a picture
of this called join.tech4uk.com
fill in your details and join us in this
endeavor
get involved you can tweet us you can
instagram us you can facebook us
join us we go on marches we hang out we
have wednesday night meetups in a pub
yes definitely so please come and join
us for that
or you can also info techforuk.com
will also reach us as well info at
anything info at pretty much
everything in info pretty much
everything at techforuk.com
so um lastly i just want to say one word
which is that best for britain who we
are working for has
a paid position going um and this
is a job for a junior probably
more junior i suppose data scientists to
perform
analysis of electoral polling data to
write analysis of trends
spot and analyze data sets uh present
and work intimately on you know
detailedly on this
on this issue it's a really really
important issue as you can tell
and we've got about five minutes left so
please join
and even if you don't want to join you
don't want a job join us
get involved and please come on let's
let's do this shall we let's have a go
go on see you later
you